I hope you've been notice that the theme here in our units are different types
of expressions. We've been learning the skills into perform operations on
polynomials, rational expressions, and now radicals. The last operation mean to
learn radicals is division. We can think of the division of two radicals as
fraction. We'll have root two divided by root five. But for radical
expressions, we don't want a radical to appear in the denominator. There are
few reasons why we want to change this. First, it's typically easier to
approximate this division if we divide it by an integer here rather than a
radical. Secondly, we can determine if the expressions are equivalent to other
expressions by changing what this fraction looks like. Keep in mind that when
we rationalize a denominator, we're going to change what the fraction looks
like but we won't change it's value. What do you think we can multiply the
numerator and denominator by so that we have a denominator without a radical?
We want to multiply by a form of 1 here so whatever we multiply this
denominator by, we'd also multiply this numerator by.